Jean-Noël il va venir nous rejoindre
dans un instant et quand on a découvert
Jean-Noël pour la première fois il avait
un petit pépin physique vous êtes tombé
sur un dentiste qui avait visiblement
pas tous ses diplômes regardez
un truc je suis allé dans un centre
dentaire pour me faire un détartrage et
j'ai fini par peur d'une dentaire
un mauvais dentiste du coup ça fait
Jacquouille la fripouille tout le monde
je suis en train de
très très heureux d'accueillir Jean-Noël
que j'adore et on t'a suivi tu nous as
fait kiffer Jean-Noël comment tu vas mon
chéri ça va très bien merci
ça y est c'est plus qu'un mauvais
souvenir exactement comment ça va est-ce
que tu as trouvé l'amour non toujours
pas toujours pas non tu as kiffé de
faire l'amour
c'est quoi ton style
je suis par exemple qui tu trouves beau
gosse
[Musique]
un style très élégant tout le monde en
fait
[Rires]
en tout cas je suis très heureux de toi
qu'est-ce qu'il fait faire l'émission ou
pas ouais franchement oui ça a été un
personnage incroyable toi merci beaucoup
toujours nous on a craqué pour toi
vraiment ouais c'est gentil tu kiffes ta
race ça se passe bien ta vie oui ça va
c'est l'amour donc ça va pas
malheureusement là
bas
alors Jean-Noël on a un autre extrait on
a mis les cinq extraits qu'on a préféré
vous il y a une autre chose qui a marqué
tout le monde c'est votre sensibilité
M6
il nous a dit qu'ils avaient
complètement explosé le budget mouchoir
pour vous dernier regardez il est
incroyable
dans ma chambre d'hôtel et un petit
souci
j'ai le covid dont je vous propose de
venir à la ferme tous les trois super
ça y est je suis arrivé
le départ de Gilbert m'a bouleversé
[Musique]
pour moi ça se passe plutôt bien je suis
assez content
je l'ai fait sur plaisir fois donc pour
moi c'est que du positif je suis waouh
je pleure
[Musique]
quand tu revois ça bonjour Noël quand on
voit ça ça te fait ça te fait un petit
truc forcément
et donc
depuis
zérobai depuis non rien du tout rien du
tout
et là tu as pu trouver vraiment pas une
tentative de
j'ai eu des approches d'accord à combien
de mètres
[Rires]
est-ce que tu as plus de succès depuis
que tu as fait l'émission oui oui quand
même vraiment ouais
je crois que qu'est-ce que tu as est-ce
que tu as quelqu'un en tête en ce moment
j'ai quelqu'un dans ma tête
il le sait il le sait dit savoir
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
ou non c'est pas un agriculteur le
problème c'est qu'il est passé
mais il s'aime bien tu sens oui tout à
fait il y a un petit des petits échanges
il y a des échanges voilà oui
téléphonique après aussi
alors suite à l'émission
voilà donc en fait j'ai eu beaucoup de
propositions sur les réseaux
sociaux via Messenger
il est avec quelqu'un mais il est avec
quelqu'un
[Applaudissements]
voilà le problème c'est que bon il est
pas seul mais
de quitter son mec
il y a eu un petit truc déjà entre vous
pas du tout non vous vous êtes vieux en
vrai non pas encore
mais on n'est pas dans la même région
si tu donnes la région
[Musique]
comme cible et aussi tu as du caractère
et je n'ai pas pour faire des petites
vannes et nous c'est ce qui fait aussi
regarde
l'utilité aucun fruit pas beaucoup de
légumes pas de mayonnaise pas de
vinaigrette tu manges pas la salade
sauce tomate avec la sauce de la salade
à la sauce tomate
avec lui
[Rires]
bon ça va alors ça s'est bien passé
bisous ma Gigi merci beaucoup en tout
cas
bisous bisous
alors et puis tu as terminé ton aventure
je t'aime beaucoup mais tu es trop bien
pour moi
je sais c'est toujours relou ça très
très compliqué surtout que lui-même
était très touché au moment de me
l'annoncer il pleurait également regarde
on va revoir la séquence que celle-là
c'était très dur ce moment je te cache
pas que j'ai versé une larme aussi
c'est parti
et c'est toujours vous êtes très très
touchant et ça va beaucoup plus
[Musique]
persuadé que je pensais
rien c'est ça qui est assez difficile à
dire
tu mérites autre chose
et je suis pas sûr
moi je pense pas que je serais capable
de
voilà
et je peux pas te faire du mal plus
longtemps quoi vraiment je veux
[Applaudissements]
tu avais vraiment des sentiments oui
plus de nouvelles après si on se
téléphone et quelques fois mais bon
voilà bon il a voulu que je reçois le
voir à un moment
de mon côté c'était pas c'était pas
possible et puis bon il est vrai aussi
que quand on visionne l'émission on
découvre certaines choses aussi des
choses qui sont tournées à côté en
dehors de est-ce que tu as découvert
qu'il t'a énervé
ce qui m'a un petit peu
c'est le fait de en fait qui qu'il est
vraiment en tête l'autre prétendant sans
vraiment chercher à me donner ma chance
et puis ce qui m'a aussi chagriné c'est
quand il a dit au bilan que ce qu'il
dérangeait c'était mon problème dedans
mais là maintenant c'est
entre le moment où il se passait combien
de temps entre le speed dating et le
jour
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
pas de souci
et après entre là et la ferme il y a
combien de temps il y a à peu près une
semaine mais impossible
des centaines de dentaires
j'étais prêt à venir sur Paris et tout
personne ne voulait pas voulu vous aider
j'aime pas cette émission précisément
pour ça quoi parce que moi je vous
trouve absolument adorable et
extrêmement charmant et hyper sensible
mais je trouve que quand la prod malgré
tout vous prend pendant une semaine
après et il savent très bien que vous
allez être sans votre dent et ben ça
vous met dans une situation de fragilité
et de faiblesse et détestable
si tu le dis ta danse à du tout
[Rires]
pour Noël
moi je trouve en plus que c'était pas
franchement c'était pas hyper gênant
il y a beaucoup de personnes qui m'ont
dit que j'ai eu énormément de courage
d'y aller mal ouais la prod ils aurai dû
te mettre un dentiste d'urgence ça a
raison
d'artiste tu m'as rappelé moi
sur ma vie je t'aurais moi j'ai un
centre dentaire moi on va vivre frère tu
me demandes j'ai tous les méchants